okay let's let's go ahead and get
started welcome everyone as you know we
occasionally within the context of the
demise informatics research conference
have specific activities you know like
clinical informatics Grand Rounds and
this is clinical informatics journal
club so our speaker today is one of our
clinical informatics fellows Thomas
Erlewine who is in his first year the
fellowship and is going to present a
paper that was published in jami'a
actually he pointed out to me I didn't
realize this but in how Kim one of our
former fellows was a co-author of this
paper Thomas I I'm not gonna pronounce
the German correctly he's originally
from Germany and went to medical school
at Cherry Tay universität medcine close
enough Berlin and then he came to the
United States where he did a residency
in internal medicine at Lincoln medical
and mental health center and now he's
pursuing training and clinical
informatics
are you getting a signal
okay so and I was then looking I was
wondering what the best ways to find an
article I looked at Jamieson fits like
or publication and amongst the articles
that were displayed there really there
was some editor's choice articles and
this one actually stood out to me
because like just looking at the title
this is I felt like one of the
fundamental questions that we've been
thrown into with the whole development
that has happened from transitioning
from paper-based records economy medical
records and so I'm going to talk about
this and my plan was we have I think an
hour my plan was to talk roughly 30 to
40 minutes and leave some time for
discussion of the topic included and
then some critical review of the how the
study was some questions
so why this article so health
information technology those who
actually work with it and clinical realm
probably know this best it can provoke a
range of emotions from excitement of
anticipation to frustration anger and
sometimes actually faces substantial
criticism there are there are employers
who actually try to use promote the
positions that they offer with saying
that they have paper-based records as a
bonus position so but there's some
controversy so the the question posed by
this article would generally have broad
implications it's a very broad question
and if we can derive it an answer to
this question this would affect what we
do how we do it how much money is spent
on this what research should be looking
at it might also make us we think of the
investments that have been done that
were substantial with the publication
jami'a in 2015 and so the author's begin
with review of what's been done before
and they found that there have been look
at outcomes of health information
technology but those systems those 31
reviews they are generally isolated from
specific technologies most commonly
clinical decision support isolated
clinical setting inpatient or
and they look at specific outcomes and
most of them actually looked at adverse
drug events and the findings were
generally mixed so overall while it may
be helpful in in the world of studies
may be helpful in answering questions
about the importance or the value of
specific interventions for specific
outcomes the general questions that we
sometimes face like bestest overall like
improve patient outcomes is there an
overall effect is not really answered by
those and they also have mixed findings
and/or like nuns sophistica not
significant findings which might which
you might be able to mitigate by pulling
them together to get a clearer picture
across the spectrum so this review
combines multiple health information
technologies in all clinical areas they
are not restricted clinical areas and it
looks at basically open is open to
anything that can be qualified as
verification safety outcomes and they
point out that it's the first of its
kind there is no other review that tries
to address this question so next I want
to talk about the study design
so just a quick review like this is
based on the user scheduler medical
literature what is the process of
actually writing a systematic review we
formulate a question and determine what
are eligible articles to go into your
review then and since most reviews cover
a diverse spectrum of articles that have
differences in the way they were
conducted there should be a priori typo
and like an anticipation hypothesis of
what differences are expected and how
they can be explained between the
studies and the search is done to find
all the articles that are relevant
titles are screen abstracts are screened
typically in the stepwise fashion and in
the end the full-text and then once
those who meet based on their full text
all the risk of bias is assessed and the
data is abstracted meaning like summary
data is that later to see if there's an
overall signal Pico or population
intervention control outcomes would be
patients were in any clinical setting it
was not limited by age it was not
limited by certain characteristics of
the population and we're under the care
of a healthcare professional and
clinical practice or postgraduate
training it's included also nurses and
pharmacists interventions work health
information technologies I'll show you
some examples of what was included
slide they may include controls there
were different types of studies included
there was a number of randomized
clinical trials that had a randomized
control route there are a number of
cohort studies there were some studies
where the comparison was done between
same group at different points in time
typically after rollout or
implementation of the outcomes for
direct patient safety outcomes which
I'll list a group them together and I'll
show you electronic health record which
was a very broad
this was actually compiled by the a
priori knowledge of the authors as well
as what they found in the systematic
reviews that they note there were a few
that they didn't find anything on like
home blood pressure cuff monitoring
devices for example where amongst tools
that they would have considered but
there were no studies they included
adverse drug events with generally
adverse events
I want to point out that there is some
are lumped together where the clinical
basis for this may not be that clear
Falls and pressure ulcers while
occurring in you could say from my
clinical experience they occur in
similar groups of patients often they
still are not the same in terms of the
clinical implication and the most most
significant discrepancy there within a
group I find us in this example here
altered Mental Status and stroke which
have very which may have very different
implications down the line for now about
the search so the sources that they
consulted were generally the recommended
ones for a systematic review or MEDLINE
and they the library in the added
because like nursing informatics also
plays a role there and this way we have
a more complete picture the time range
included was January 1st and they also
looked at conference proceedings and
they looked at references of the article
were selected and the prior systematic
reviews I assume this I understand this
refers to the 31 more focused systematic
reviews from before that I mentioned in
earliest life so and the strategy was a
combination of keywords and controlled
vocabulary and they also use a filter to
look for patient safety as the topic in
their search strategy they mention the
detailed search strategy a description
in the appendix but however I was not
able to access the appendix web version
of the article
and studies were then evaluated for
their quality based on a 10-point scale
so this scale was taken from one of the
or who's actually used in several of the
systematic reviews that were listed
earlier it doesn't seem to have a
particular name but it it's relatively
common to use like a typically like
three to four different criteria for
quality and break them
baseline characteristics
what they looked at and they scored it
from zero to T highest quality and then
subgroup analysis was planned for those
who had positive results meaning an
improvement in patient outcomes those
who had makes their non significant
results and a separate subdued analysis
of randomized control trials because
they are so and now I'm going to go over
the findings this is the you can call it
floaties of what they found with the
numbers so the important thing is they
found with their search spreader to you
six six thousand one hundred thirty
eight articles after removing those that
were not English language we've looked
at 4700 remained they added a few based
on references that they reviews from
this was all done by one person up to
this point and after the abstracts that
did not fit the inclusion criteria were
the next steps were them with two people
like there was
hundred thirty five remaining articles
and so then they look for the they
decided which ones to keep by consensus
overall the reviewer agreement was
relatively high ninety four percent
chance corrected and for the quadratic
weighted Kappa 88.9 system so and here's
a descriptive analysis at least for each
type of health information technologies
they found at least one article and
there was more than one health
information technology used in twenty
two studies so the number said you'll
see they're gonna exceed one hundred
percent so it was here in fifteen
percent this is an excerpt from the
table and this first column here's the
main one to look at it's the number and
you can see that the most common ones
were clinical decision support and
together I want to point out the amount
to ninety seven percent so you would
have to and if you look at it there's
more than a hundred percent because of
the presence of more than one health
information technology in some of the
studies but still you can see that
whatever conclusion we are going to draw
it's mainly gonna be based on what's
been done on clinical decision support
and computerized physician order
anything
here's some numbers on the setting
conditions
most of them were done in the inpatient
setting but human the outpatient setting
only one and with long-term care
settings and the clinicians effectors
were in a 80% positions working for some
nurses then they assess the quality as
for the scale if so low quality
intermediate quality would be a score of
four to six and high quality seven to
ten and you can see that the
intermediate group is at about forty
nine percent and there's only 22 percent
that would be considered high quality
and the weakest aspects that they found
were a randomization and allocation the
majority of studies failed to randomize
patients or even have a concurrent
control group and it was mostly
allocated at the patient level 81% were
done without blinding however the
follow-up was overall really good ninety
the majority 61 percent having more than
90% follow-up you can see the
distribution between the different study
types
randomized control trials for study the
largest people's cohort and observation
the article said will come the articles
at the outcomes actually here's a list
of the outcomes so again the here's the
majority is picking up by actually by
adverse drug reactions or adverse events
as well as the readmission admission or
emergency visit and mortality and maybe
thrombosis and leave the rest has been I
want to point out in this context that
one of the studies there was only one
that showed an increase like a negative
outcome pediatric ICU where they
introduced utilized provider order entry
they looked at the mortality it was
about a year before introduction in the
five months after and they found in
relatively large study comprised about
2,000 patients that he actually went up
significantly however this is an the
only one that showed that here are the
positive studies they called the
positive studies refers to those that
had a positive impact
and those were mostly observational 40
percent in cohort studies mostly single
Center in the United States and 96
percent were in the imitations
however otherwise there were no
significant significant difference in
sample size and quality score compared
to other studies and adverse events who
was the largest one that showed a
reduction I'm not sure what percentage
of that would be worst drug events but
that's the significance of more positive
results that makes were also found for
length of stay impairment here's some
details of the other subgroup so the
next study states that call it mixed
when there was either an non significant
outcome or there was there were several
outcome measures and there was a
contradiction between
yeah this is the other piece where the
secondary patient I'll consider positive
but the primary a group of randomized
controlled trials 18 total had only
positive trials and most of them studied
the authors concluded after looking at
the results that most studied short
mixed or non significant results which
is not unexpected based on the more
focused reviews that they had seen
before there's a paucity of outpatient
studies and a paucity of randomized
controlled trials they also say that
large studies are needed because of the
relatively rare how tightly modifiable
outcomes this is something where I think
it depends on the type of health
information technology but they're
making it easier for a larger sample
sizes and they also state that one
barrier to research might be the high
cost of purchase of information
technology however if you compare that
to the development of research and
development and eventually like study
and marketing off something like cancer
drug development those costs are
clinical decision support is the most
commonly studied and the reasons for
that are probably that it's easy to
randomize and it's easy to apply across
different centers the other conclusions
are they notice that the clinical
decision supports this systems comprise
a very heterogeneous pool a better
nomenclature for health information
technologies might actually enable
better characterization and comparison
between the tools and with across
different studies there are only a few
studies for a lot of the other health
information technologies so really we
just have mostly data on clinical
decision support and the computerized
provider order entry a publication bias
was mentioned as a possibility and that
based on experiences with publication
bias the number the percentage of
positive outcomes with health
information technology might actually be
even lower however they did not support
that with any estimate of the
publication bias they noticed
furthermore that many aspects are vastly
under study of health information
technology because as you all probably
know health information technology is
far more than clinical decision support
and utilize provider order entry and at
this stage is unclear which types of
health IT have a better impact on care
so I want to go over the critique of the
article and I followed this outline from
the users guide to another to a dessert
question sensible search done properly
with the risk of fire assess was the
difference between the studies explained
are the results applicable are they
reproducible and it's the confidence in
the effects so this year I think is
actually a while I think that the
question is probably on a lot of
people's minds and it's important to ask
the question is probably too broad at
least in comparison to what we have and
in terms of literature at this point
which is still an evolving field and
they have a grab in the article which
shows that the number of publications
has been steadily increasing over time
I would also argue that the health
information technology tools probably
have a very different effect on patient
care and because their nature is very
different between like a clinical
reminder and like a computerized
physician order entry with medication
cross-checking there's probably a large
differences picture so lumping together
in one study may dilute actually the the
title of mentioned patient outcomes but
this is alone the ticking was actually
patient safety outcomes that the study
focus on and enough patient outcomes in
general and the patient population was
kept relatively open I assume the goal
of the study was to make a broad claim
if possible with the available studies
however
yeah this the population was not really
to limit the search was a detail in
exhaustive they covered the primary
sources that should be searched as well
as additional ones that are reasonable
in the context of however there was no
formal exploration of possible
publication bias this is an area of
controversy and you know but an estimate
at least would have given some some
better foundational discussing the
possibility
well they stated made a statement on
this one like the absence of a conflict
of interest of their article like there
was no statement on conflicts of
interest or sponsorship in primary
studies I could also not access the
appendix with details which might rather
be but I assume is rather technological
problem of the total web presence of
team what's the risk of fires so I think
the comprehensive endpoint assessment is
probably one of the strengths of the it
goes a little beyond what you'd usually
expect with like weed or factor
assessment however I noticed that the
sample size was not taken into account
in this in this and
there were a large variations in sample
size from like a few dozen to 20,000
study subjects there was a detailed
analysis done off certain subgroups
it's an assumed they were determined a
priori so here we don't really have like
most of the studies were non significant
or mixed in their results so we don't
really have anything that we think
included in there which may be because
of the broad question
and also probably because there is a
relative paucity of studies 69 studies
on an entire field like this that were
included it's a relatively low number
for selection in the fifteenth of
studies were producible so they were
here including criteria although the
search was mostly done by just one
reviewer so there's a little bit of a
possibility that there was some bias
abused later on that was good at being
in did the review address conference so
they looked at the quantity and quality
of the studies and they discussed the
possibility of publication bias in the
studies themselves they had a large
variation in sample sizes only 22% had a
high quality score
however the follow-up was relatively
complete this does not seem to be this
refused to be consistent with the mostly
makes non significant results that were
also shown in prior studies so overall I
think the study was done reasonably well
with some limitations probably primarily
dictated by the nature of the question
and the one factor there's also that
informatics and I didn't point that out
so far but an informatics it's not the
same as using one drug that can be
administered under reproducible settings
in different locations as as we know
from clinical experience using the same
health information technology tool in a
different like workplace context may
have very different results these are
probably the things that are most
affecting the the clinical question and
like lack of a definitive answer or the
answer that at this point we do not see
anything significant so yeah overall
methodological sound I think that the
question might actually come from a
specific historical point in time that
we're at like it's the kind of thing
that your health information technology
is probably the kind of thing that we're
not to get fully taken for granted but
in 10 to 20 years another generation
will will and it may be similar to when
physicians actually started treating
patients being becoming the primary
viewers I'm saying that because at the
time like now we take it for granted
that if somebody has a medical condition
medical problem that they seek a
physician in most cases in a few hundred
years back this was not typically done
by physicians that was actually a
relatively new profession and at the
time the question could have been asked
to physicians provide better care than
what we had used before and the answer
may also not have been easy or may not
have so many effects the point that I'm
trying to make is that thinking about
the impact of like looking at is art I
think that it's not going to have a
large impact because there are other
societal changes happening that are
driving this and it's not primarily
driven by patient outcomes
so I conclude also that it's likely
easier at this point to make
determinations if you focus on more
specific research questions narrow
narrow setting specific intervention and
the other take-home message I think is
that there is a huge need to study
things more thoroughly like we do not
have the data on a lot of the things
that we are actually rolling out and
that I really like like new technologies
or like you mainly have data like this
review on give arise provider order
entry and but the field is much larger
than that so there's probably huge
opportunities to actually try to study
other health information technologies
this is from I said do you have any
questions or comments
I know question about safety culture was
there a discussion about safety culture
as a confounding variable or any and did
any of the studies report on the safety
culture of the organization along with
their findings no there was no
discussion of the safety culture in the
primary article and not that I did not
get to review all the primary studies
but that could not see
so did the review article take into
account potential differences in terms
of the duration of change in terms of
the time observed from when the IT
system was implemented to when they're I
would imagine that in terms of
implementing a system like that it may
be a certain period of a theory
depending on what you're looking at in
terms of when you start to see an actual
system that's a very good point I'm
gonna pull up the table actually it's a
long table of there is in those
parameters there's a large variability
between the studies and often it's not
reported here study period months is
probably the closest working with clean
from this table and you can see it over
years almost a decade through just the
one to two year period or less in many
cases we don't know when they actually
implemented the system so we don't we
don't know what the distance is no some
of them may report it but yeah so I have
a second question that's unrelated
well tangentially related I guess but
it's kind of related to what this
article seems to be concluding which is
that you have effectively a paucity of
research on the effect of IT on what
happens in the hospital in terms of
outcomes in general yeah so to me just
as outside looking at I'm an autism
researcher and I have to pour through
probably on the order of about two
thousand articles in a given year
I'm just kind of struck by how few
articles they found starting only with
6,000 so do you have an idea or
speculation as to why there seems to be
so little publication on the issue given
that just out again outside looking in
as somebody who's not a clinician and
this seems like an important question
for everybody
I have a few theories about that but I I
would assume this as a combination of it
being relatively new to the spotlight
question on the other hand that the
money spent is usually not spent in in
that way on research like drug
development for example Leeds Leeds
passed like all those requirements at
the a requirements that require like
queens of effectiveness which we do not
have here the the incentives came from a
different direction and is actually tied
more like the it seems to be tired more
to like a quality improvement movement
which is not as much about like rigorous
methodology in terms of like scientific
from like remove bias and rather like
monitoring the performance in a setting
overtime and which is not as far as I
know not as often on public interests
and I'm sure if anybody else wants to
comment on that has a broader
perspective on this than I do but paper
but but in terms of that specific
question you know we have in our
department a systematic review Factory
upstairs and it's pretty common you know
if you are wanting to do a systematic
review on the treatment of congestive
heart failure you know patient outcomes
you will likely the search and and I too
am NOT able to get to the search and you
actually should have emailed the problem
but you know typically in a systematic
review this Aaron Cohen is not here
because he's done some informatics work
on on how to make systematic reviews
more efficient but you cast this really
huge net with a really broad search and
then you typically get 20 30 40 articles
you know some of the big systematic
reviews the ones that have made the
National Press upstairs like mammography
and use of statins and things like that
have a pretty common pretty common
outcome I guess the Michael you know I
this was an interesting paper when it
was published and there were some really
confusing things about it and actually
in retrospect III think these issues
should have been raised well the huge
issue is the the difference between the
title and what they actually did you
know the fact that that they actually
were focused on patient safety outcomes
you know and in fact I mean there you
know again I remember looking at it at
the time and wondering but you know
there's not for example some of the
David Bates studies didn't looks like
they didn't make it into their inclusion
criteria you know which is kind of
surprising
and and and then you know this focus on
on patient safety outcomes is a little
nebulous too because there are you know
there's many other kinds of outcomes as
you talked about I also note and some
others like Karen in this room might be
interesting there's only like two
studies that met their inclusion on
health information exchange we actually
upstairs
did a systematic review on health
information exchange and we we let a lot
of studies in but you know last studies
looked at other kinds of issues like
cost and you know other kinds of patient
outcomes besides safety outcomes so I
could go on and on I want to let other
people make their comments but some
interesting
so I just went to add two thoughts the
first is I wonder how much weight it is
placed in the fact that the the
literature especially the clinical
decision support literature is dominated
by studies from very few institutions
and the usual suspects are and we know
we all know who they are and I think I
think that fundamentally changes the
nature of a literature in a systematic
search when the skew is so much towards
just three or four institutions the
Brigham's the the reading stories that
have published so extensively on those
and then second Thomas could you go back
on your slides please to the big towards
the beginning where you talk where it
chooses the number of the search
strategy and the number of studies that
they looked at this one please so so I
thought this was actually interesting
that they did a primary literature
search and came up with you know six
thousand articles reduced it to forty
seven hundred and then they actually
kind of looked at references of other
papers and added three hundred and forty
four so to me that's a that's an
indication like Bill said you know the
net is really wide and then you try and
trawl in you know and some fish and and
and throw up the Dolphins and keep the
tuna I guess but but in reality to me
you know when they're looking at other
papers and they're adding you know ten
percent of their eight percent of their
of their citations based on on on on
other references to me that suggests
that the net wasn't I wasn't as
comprehensive as you would like it to be
so that's something to just kind of keep
in mind
oh I have no frontal lobe so I offered
what one it really a question did they
talk about other systematic reviews you
know because there there is this kind of
sometimes called the health affairs
methodology because some of the reviews
actually appeared in the journal Health
Affairs that I mean the the the
conclusions from those studies were a
lot more positive and and I I'm not
actually necessarily saying that their
conclusions are wrong here you know I
think that that we have we've had a
challenge in this field of evaluating
our systems often times people get
grants to implement something and then
the evaluation is put off and it never
gets done it's difficult to you know
it's not easier to do a experimental
study of giving someone a pill versus a
placebo you know as opposed to
implementing computerized physician
order entry in a hospital but one thing
that I another thing that I don't see in
the paper did they talk at all about
comparing with the other because there
had been these systematic reviews dating
back to the one by Chowdhury and Bunton
and and then the fourth was by Spencer
Jones and those reviews kind of painted
a positive picture although some people
argue that that that positivity was
actually a little bit unjustified but
did they compare their methodology with
those systematic reviews they didn't
except for like the grading of the
quality of the articles it seems to be
coming from
but otherwise I did not see you
comparison so comment in a question I
think one of the things that's hard
about also just health IT and for me
with with research and in general is
also the difference between patient
outcomes and process outcomes and that
kind of some of the things that we
measure it because when I'm looking
through this paper when I'm trying to
look at some of the outcomes that they
were measuring even from a safety
standpoint you know mortality I mean
there are so many things that go into
that and so many things that are beyond
the scope of IT so what effect is IT
having on mortality can be very hard to
directly link whether or not health I
just the implementation of the health I
sees IT system influencing mortality I
think vision you've talked about this
where there was I can't remember where
it was I think was who did I might have
been haladki but they implemented IT
they and they show that that it
increased mortality and they said well
the IT system failed and failing to
recognize that the implementation
changed so much about the culture the
institution there were all these other
factors that were being changed and the
whole idea of the unintended
consequences and so just the
implementation itself is hard to show
that that implementation in and of
itself is having an effect the other
thing I find that's difficult with
research and one of the things we see
you know for example you go back to your
drug example well if we find that a drug
works as a institution we can buy that
drug and decide to buy it well for the
software if we have epic and they built
it on Cerner no matter how much we want
to pay we can't implement it there are
limitations to that as well and you know
buying the software and being able to
actually own it regardless of how much
benefit we show or how much however much
benefit it has I think that's a
limitation to me in general you talk
about that the limitations of
clickability
and that's it to me it's it's hard when
you say that this software was a
proprietary software or this software
only works on this system you know those
are some limitations I see when I
research or when I just read about these
kind of studies the question I have for
you maybe as a group is how do these
studies take into consideration the fact
that health IT is iterative in nature
and goes through version control
like what happens when the software is
implemented but then they do version 2
and version 3 you know how do you then
determine the effect that has on the
same thing that you were measuring well
they were probably these separate
studies as far as I know they have not
looked at like longer they've done like
either like case like intervention
control group division concurrently or
they looked at the same group at two
different points in time but I also want
to add that I think that you you're
totally right there and I think that
when an institution rolls out something
as major as an EHR was listed here as
the information technology then that may
go along with a lot of other
institutional changes the money
investment is huge and some other things
may change they may need to change their
leadership structure as they introduce
it and the EHR has also a ripple effect
on all kinds of other parts of the
system I think this is a little bit of a
comment and then maybe just kind of
getting your thoughts on it as well but
it seems kind of like as others have
mentioned and as you mentioned that a
lot of the research is driven not by
actual necessarily
hypothesis-driven things that are that
are from research to to delivering care
but instead are based on quality
improvement or on business processes and
simply evaluating how those things
happened in a observational or
retrospective manner and I think that's
one problem that we have in terms of
generating good data on the effects of
these things and I I wonder if that's in
part and whether this might be changing
because these healthcare technologies
are not really thought of or considered
by regulatory agencies or by a lot of us
as as actual treatments or therapies or
things that are part of the medical care
of a patient or of populations and
whether we may need to make some changes
in how we think about those things in
terms of oh I'm gonna put in a new piece
of technology do I need to actually go
through some trials go through some
phase one trials in order to actually
get that thing approved for use in a in
a new clinical setting and and I think
it's starting to happen if I remember
right the FDA actually has just approved
one of the first apps or some I think
it's drug cessation therapy has actually
clinically approved as a thing so it's
sort of like a medical device or a drug
or another therapy and we may need to
kind of go down that route in order to
start having more rigorous evaluations
of new new things within the health IT
sort of space otherwise it's just gonna
be free-for-all and we'll never know
whether anything's actually helpful um
yes
what I would add to that is that I think
it's characterized at the moment not
that there's like a lack in general of
doing that evaluation like we have
groups like at the VA and here who look
at like impact sometimes more sometimes
that's the it's more characterized right
now that this is not uniform like an
institution that can afford to conduct
studies before made in doing changes and
that seeds the use in that might be more
likely at academic institutions than not
I'm just assuming that of that but those
institutions are probably more likely to
do that for their own interest while
those who do not have a lot of financial
leeway and are spending a lot of money
on like an information technology they
might not have the means to do any such
assessment and just like go with what
they get so one of the things are really
striking me about this from an
analogical perspective is the issue of
introducing analytics in sports and
particularly in baseball through the mid
90s through the early to mid 2000s and
this in many ways from a problem
perspective seems to parallel that in
terms of you have to effectively change
the culture the downside that I'm
starting to realize and that may be
affecting why you don't have quality
science is that there's no real innate
incentive to do this on the on the
perspective from the perspective of the
hospital so in the case of baseball for
example what really spurred you know the
Moneyball quote-unquote or analytics
movement was teams winning because teams
could win and make money as a result of
it here I the incentives are a lot
murkier in terms of the implement in
terms of whether you should implement it
that makes the case for pushing it a lot
harder as a result so I'm wondering if
that may be driving somewhat though the
what what I'm seeing is kind of
a murky low interest in terms of really
being able to do this as rigorously as
possible and implement good standards
and practices to make sure that people
are doing this right I agree there's not
really a defined standard to compare how
different hospitals perform so there are
some ways but so I thought about this
which is that I mean it's a resource
problem to some extent so if you have
big hospitals or big institutions they
can do this so if you have a network so
you can shunt information from lower
clinical settings or clinical things
that don't have that capacity to
clinical settings that do have that type
of research capacity you could start
getting some handle on that data I you
know I think your points are well-taken
but just to add some perspective though
I mean you know one is that I mean
there's no question I don't think anyone
even the most rigorous defenders of IT
and health care would would argue that
there have not been enough studies but
on the other hand sometimes we you know
the FDA approves drugs after a clinical
trial of you know a thousand or 2,000
patients and then it's you know it's
given to millions so we're not
necessarily unique in that regard you
know in terms of incentives I mean
people do have incentives informatics
researchers have incentives for their
systems to do well so that when they go
back to the NLM or AHRQ for the next
grant you know though that they'll get
it or they'll you know they'll have
shown that that they did so successfully
you know I I think that hospitals and
clinicians probably have some incentives
to I mean they want to do you know
what's best for their patients but but
you know I also again coming back to
something I said earlier and again you
know not this isn't really an excuse for
anything but you know as one who has
done systematic review is actually not
only of health information exchange but
telemedicine over the years the the
outcomes
our multifaceted and the EHR or CPOE
whatever is only one tool that may or
may not you know get you to do the right
thing so you know that that's why and
and you know the a few people talked
about the cultural differences you know
in hospitals and things like that those
things are huge
but you know it you know it's it's
different in every place again it's just
so much easier and I'm not saying we
shouldn't do research but it's so much
easier you know to take a patient with
disease X and give them either drug Y or
placebo and and to do a study and and so
you know if nothing else I think the
take-home lesson here is how complex
these kinds of evaluations are but that
that's not a reason not to do them and
not to pursue them
so this is really also I think for bill
we've read so many of these studies now
that have tried to prove one way or the
other that EHRs affect outcome and most
of these studies whether they're
analyses like these or others fall flat
I mean they don't provide us with a
definitive answer to the question so
knowing that this is a complex socio
technical issue and that there are many
parameters associated with this and if
when you study these complex social
technical systems with emergent
properties it's tough to show outcomes
and that many of these studies are
retrospective that look at data that was
collected for other purposes and and
that's a bad thing but my question
really is what is it going to take or
what do you think the future holds what
kind of research will then produce this
the answer to this question that we're
trying to ask which is what is the
effect of of EHRs on patient outcomes
how do we actually where do you think
the the the hockey-puck will be ten
years from now will we be in a position
to make this determination or is it
still going to be an unanswered question
in the future is my question
well I mean one approach to that look
really covering this your butt is still
doing population studies and maybe
comparing the like data on the
healthcare system before EHR
implementation on a larger scale and
afterwards it's a good way to assess it
and there's a high potential for
confounders if you deflect the time
frame you may at least like have a sense
of what you could face some more
detailed research on
okay
I don't know you know it's easy like
bill mentioned its easiest for us to
figure this out for drugs because you
can the way that you can find the
answers are easy the the question I
really have is you know are we are we
actually asked is asking the question
itself beyond the scope of what EHRs can
do like they'll mention it's just a tool
in an armamentarium of tools that we use
should we be looking at much more
specific things for the use of that tool
rather than ask the question or are they
gonna improve outcomes we're not going
to ask the question about you know
specific things like central lines I
mean even for for drugs I mean this is
just my opinion like for drugs it's it's
not that a stat I mean we say statins
reduce mortality but the effect of that
is by lowering cholesterol which we know
that reduces mortality and it has
anti-inflammatory so I think the EHR
when they say it reduces mortality well
what are the intermediate steps what are
the things in between from mortality to
EHR what are the things about mortality
that we know reduce mortality and how
does the EHR affect that if we ask those
questions I think that is where you can
then start to look at the direct effect
of an EHR on that element of it because
even for me like that abstraction of you
know mortality again that's why I'm
saying like length of state there's so
many things that go into that but if we
break it down into some elements that we
know affect the length of stay if we
break it down if these bigger outcome
measures into smaller things that we
know can be broken down or no have an
effect on that then I think we can start
measuring what the effect of EHRs is on
that to me the one of the hardest
challenge is what is the placebo what is
the placebo of an EHR we can have an
implementation how do you have the
placebo how do you blind someone how do
you do a double-blind to study that
element that we know is very good at
showing cause and effect for what effect
what is the this this drug or whatever
this treatment is has the effect and we
know that by having double blinded
randomized can randomized double
blinding if we can get through that if
we can figure that element out I think
that could go a long way if we can't
then maybe there's a different paradigm
to look at I mean
at least that way but those were my two
questions because again it's and that's
why I talked about process measures as
opposed to outcome measures you know
like for example hand washing is it the
hand washing itself or is it being told
that you have to wash your hand that had
an impact is it the the type of you know
just is it the fact that you're using
alcohol-based vs. washing your hands or
is it just the fact that you're knowing
about it that's making an impact you
know so that that has come up and so
that's why I thought about when I say
more talent we needed to say mortality
I'm like well more tallies 100% at the
end of the day everyone's gonna die
sometime but like what are you trying to
impact here length this day is like
eventually someone's leaving for trying
to reduce it how many different things
go into that I mean I was just talking
to the Thomas on the way here I'm saying
as a doctor the things that I know look
reduce length of stay are having good
social workers and case managers not
having a good EHR so like I mean there
are so many things that reduce length of
stay that's beyond just the impact of an
EHR so and that's when I say like are we
even asking the right questions when
we're studying some of these things
[Applause]